[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me suis
payé un beau
chapeau pour avoir l'air bien comme il
le faut quand je croise mes amis ils en
crèvent de jalousie en voyant mon beau
chapeau j'ai mis un
ruban sur mon
chapeau parce que ça fait plus
rigolo en voyant coiffer ainsi toutes
les jolies filles
SC quel beau
Chau je passe mon temps soir et matin
devant les classes des
magasins je me
regarde je me plais bien et ma
[Musique]
pas bien droit mon beau chapeau pour
piloter ma petite
auto comme ce n'est pas très pratique
j'ai fixé un élastique pour tenir mon
beau
chapeau le seul malheur c'est que le
nuit alors que j'étais faut bien le dire
un tout petit peu gris on a changé à mon
insu
le nom est numéro de ma rue moi je me
suis fé à mon chapeau et je suis
rentré
directo à l'adresse qui était marquée
c'est comme ça que j'ai réveillé le
capitaine des
pompiersun chapau à cette chanson qui
n'a ni rime ni raison
je crois bien l'avoir trouvé car pour
m'avoir écouté je vous tire mon
chap